well I was pretty fascinated by this the
New York Times ran an editorial
yesterday take a look at this headline
it says wear clothes then you're part of
the problem you know I have to say I was
pretty shocked that The Times is now
running Katie Hills internal staff memos
as an editorial I I didn't expect that I
mean hasn't this woman suffered enough
just leave her alone for God's sake
she's the victim in this remember but
actually no this isn't if you look
closer this isn't from Katie hill
surprisingly enough this is an
environmentalist thing this is the Times
arguing that you're killing the
environment by wearing clothing and and
this they're not just referring to
people like myself who go and kill baby
polar bears to harvest their fur for
slippers which is a completely legit
legitimate hobby by the way but frowned
upon these days no they're saying that
if you wear any clothing at all you're
killing the planet so of course if the
choice is between killing the planet or
having to look at everybody naked
probably the former would be the wiser
choice have you seen people recently but
really think about what the
environmentalists want from us now okay
they want us not driving not taking
airplanes not using electricity eating
bugs going around naked and they wonder
why their message isn't resonating it's
it's a mystery it's a real mystery
because it should be so viscerally
appealing this idea that we can live you
that they're inviting us to live like
it's the year 200,000 BC who wouldn't
want that run around naked eat bugs eat
worms and beetles died from a tooth
infection when you're 37 it's a great
life a short life but a great life so
but for some reason people aren't into
it I just I can't quite figure that out
okay today we're gonna talk about we got
a bunch of to talk about today including
a big bombshell from Project Veritas and
James O'Keefe this one is a this is a
literal bombshell well not a literal
bombshell that's that's that would be
not safe but this is a big story we're
gonna talk about that also remember the
if you remember that reporter who dug up
dirt on the guy who was doing charity
work for kids
Carson King and the reporter tried to
cancel him based
the old tweets city had written but then
the reporter ended up getting cancelled
instead remember that
well he's speaking out now and and he he
wrote an article and has revealed that
apparently he hasn't learned a damn
thing surprisingly and a prominent
abortionist celebrates his birthday in
inappropriately disturbing way but I
also have a clip from this abortionist
that completely decimates pretty much
every pro-abortion talking point and I
want to play that for you today but
first a word from light stream you know
the holidays are approaching and you may
be thinking about how you're gonna save
some extra money well I've got an idea
because we're all we all have this in
mind right as the holidays come up I got
an idea that maybe you haven't thought
of yet you can consolidate your high
interest credit card balances to a lower
rate and save with light stream get a
rate as low as five point nine five
percent APR with Auto pay it's much
lower than national average interest
rate of over twenty percent APR so just
compare you know five point nine five
percent with twenty percent that's how
much you're saving plus your rate is
fixed so as the rate continues to rise
as rates continued rise everyone else's
rates yours are gonna stay low and so
you get that peace of mind you're not
only saving money but for me a lot of
this is about saving money but it's also
about just a peace of mind that comes
with that stability and knowing that
you're making the right financial
decision just for my listeners apply now
to get a special interest rate discount
the only way to get this discount listen
to this is to go to light stream comm
slash Walsh Li gh T STR e am comm /
Walsh okay so you know sometimes you
hear people hyping up bombshells
and then the bomb goes off and it's more
of a firecracker really at best this one
though this one I think is really big
James O'Keefe and Project Veritas they
have footage of ABC anchor amy robach
and this is about as damning as it can
possibly get for a news organization
listen to this she told me everything
she had pictures she had everything she
was in hiding for 12 years we convinced
her to come out we convinced her to talk
to us
it was unbelievable what we had Clinton
we have everything I for three years to
get it on to no avail and now it's all
coming out and it's like these new
relevant regulations and I freaking had
on all of it I I I'm just so pissed
right now like every day I get more and
more pissed because I'm just like oh my
god we it was on what what we had was
unreal
so that that is is damning on a number
of levels for ABC so you have you have
corruption and you have incompetence
that's being revealed here here by by
the anchor the anchor who you know you
want to give her credit because
according to her anyway she she wanted
to get this story up and she was trying
to push the story but at the same time
it's clear from the clip I just played
there that her main concern that the
main thing she's upset about is that she
didn't get credit for the story you know
I think anyone it's it's okay to be
upset about that I think anyone would be
I mean anyone would feel that way to a
certain extent you feel like you had a
big story that your bosses wouldn't let
you go with and someone else gets the
story but it is disturbing that you
don't see quite the concern for the
victims that you would hope to see but
that's not really the point here the
point is what it reveals about ABC so
first you've got the fact that they
didn't recognize according to her they
didn't recognize the Epstein story as a
big story at first they said who's
Epstein nobody cares and this was what
three years ago I mean three years ago I
knew that Epstein was a big story most
of us knew that Epstein was a big story
they didn't realize that and then you've
got the corruption of as they start to
see that it's a big story and they see
the powerful people are implicated they
decide not to run it because of that
because they're worried about the
repercussions and I mean we could only
expect well she says that the palace got
involved and so they were worried about
whatever repercussions would come from
that and she says they had Clinton every
but he was in it so I think we can
assume that there was also the political
angle of ABC not wanting to take down a
Democrat this is there really is no
coming back from something like this
given the source and you know it would
been very courageous of the anchor if
she had come out sometime in the last
three years and actually exposed this
and said hey I've had this story ABC
well let me run it well here's the story
that would have been great she didn't do
it didn't have the guts for that but in
some ways now that we get the now that
we hear this allegation the way that we
do it's much more pouts more powerful
than if she'd come out and said it
because then you could always accuse of
a lie of her her of lying and so on but
the fact that we get this allegation and
she didn't know that this did she was
just talking whoever she was talking to
she thought it was private she didn't
know it was gonna get out there that
makes it very powerful and compelling
and there's nothing that ABC can I'm
sure they'll think of something but
there's really no coming back from this
or there's really no way to salvage your
reputation whatever reputation they that
they had which wasn't much to begin with
this is why yeah I sound like a broken
record all of conservatives in media
sound like a broken record saying this
but this is why people hate the media if
you're in the media and you feel very
persecuted and put upon because people
like Donald Trump called you the enemy
of the people
why do you think that resonates so much
I mean you could sit there and with your
martyr complex and say everybody hates
us I don't know why or you can consider
what what have we done that would make
people hate us so much why is it so
popular when when when Donald Trump
launches it to his anti media thing why
is that always such a hit it could be
that everyone is evil and they're out to
get you and you're perfect it could be
that or it could be stuff like this
because although this is a bombshell and
it's damning it's also not surprising
nobody is surprised by that this is
exactly the kind of thing that we assume
the media did that we knew the media did
and this is why we don't like the media
because we can't trust it and if we
can't trust you in the news media then
what what do what purpose do you serve
if you don't have trust then you have
nothing all right speaking of the media
you may remember the story of Aaron
Calvin well you probably don't actually
because nobody remembers anything for
more than 35 minutes but Aaron Calvin
was that reporter over at the Des Moines
Register who wrote a profile on Carson
King that's the local hero who raised a
bunch of money for for Sick Kids we'll
originally he raised money for himself
for beer money and then he said you know
what actually will well give it to kids
instead and in the profile that that
Aaron Calvin did you may recall it
included some information about
offensive tweets that King had sent like
a decade ago and King was forced to
publicly apologize than a huge backlash
blew up against the reporter and the Des
Moines Register for publishing
irrelevant dirt on this guy who's only
famous for writing a funny sign and then
raising money for four kids somebody dug
through Calvin's so then someone other
people dug through Calvin's own Twitter
history and found a bunch of offensive
tweets of his and he was fired okay so
that's the that's the review of that
story well now he's back several weeks
later with an article in the Columbia
Journalism Review
reflecting on his experiences and here's
the big shocker here he still hasn't
learned anything he basically stands by
the decision to publish this stuff about
Carson King about his about his a tweets
he still hasn't had the Epiphany that
canceled culture is bad he's still
refusing to acknowledge that this is a
problem in our society this thing of
digging up dirt on people and trying to
destroy them randomly for no discernible
reason now a couple of things here
well it it seems like Calvin
the reporter at the Des Moines Register
is the only guy who was fired and he
seems a little bit salty about that I
don't blame him for that I I think
that's wrong because it sounds like his
editor or at least he claims that his
editor is the one who told him to go to
do a background check on Carson King
again that's a background check on a guy
who held a sign and raise money for kids
let's do a background check on him as if
he is applying to you know be an FBI
agent or something he says that an
editor told him to do it and then
obviously an editor approved the article
before it was published
and yet Calvin was the only one who was
fired so I think that's wrong and he was
fired for the wrong reasons - he was
fired because of the tweets that people
dug up that he had written years ago
when know that's that that wasn't our
point we weren't saying he should be
fired for that what we're saying is he
should be fired for writing this
incredibly irresponsible
profile and and publishing damaging
information about a private citizen for
no reason it doesn't advance the public
good
it's not newsworthy there's no reason to
do it everyone responsible for that
decision should have been fired but
that's not what happened also Calvin
said he got a bunch of death threats and
so on and and that's that's obviously
wrong as someone who myself has been the
target of that kind of treatment you
know it's it's hard for someone who's
never been targeted by the outraged mob
with the death threats and the death
wishes and all of that it's hard to
understand how overwhelming and scary
that can be
yeah it's of course it's scary because
you don't all these people you don't
know who they are which of them could be
crazy and actually be serious about what
they're saying who knows especially when
you have a family but this is exactly my
point
this is the kind of situation that the
media often puts other people in so
think about the Covington Catholic kids
it's a situation they put those kids in
that situation for no reason it's
essential
they could have put Carson King in if
the store hadn't story hadn't gone in
the in the other direction and it ended
up flying back in the faces of the Des
Moines Register and yet this is a lesson
that Calvin refuses to take from all
this he refuses to take this lesson in
fact he still denies that canceled
culture is even a problem here's what he
says on that I just thought this was
fascinating after everything he's been
through and after everything everybody
was saying you know why we objectives
here's here's what he said he said
meanwhile I lost my job work that I was
good at and proud of my family has deep
roots in Iowa and I grew up reading the
register the writer Jessie single
gleefully pointed out on Twitter the
irony of the fact that I had shared a
New Republic article on the fallacy of
canceled culture before I was fired he
shared an article of fallacy of canceled
culture meaning he shared an article
about why the counselor canceled culture
doesn't really exist or it's not a
problem and he continues but I still
don't I still don't believe in the
boogeyman of canceled culture I was not
cancelled I was fired that's an
important distinction I'm far from the
first person to be docstore to endure an
online mob it's more of a common
occurrence and turns more quickly
violent for women or writers of color
with the support of my partner in my
friends and family I was able to avoid
collapsing beneath the weight of the
great hatred directed toward me some of
my former colleagues at the register
have reached out to communicate their
support blah blah blah the specter of
canceled culture is a concept most often
invoke to protect those in power often
straight white men such as myself from
facing consequences for their actions
but I want no part in it I'm not going
to start a YouTube channel railing
against the perceived dangers of PC
culture I believe I lost my job unfairly
at the same time I firmly believe that
people especially those in power should
be held accountable for what they say
and what they do yes except that Carson
King is not a person in power that's the
whole point and you're holding him
responsible for some crap that he posted
ten years ago when he was a kid and this
is how it is with the media they just
think they keep it
they're incapable of learning and no
matter what happens if they ever suffer
any backlash or if they suffer the same
kind of treatment that they heap on
other people it never has the the effect
of making them stop and say hey you know
wow there's never any self reflection
never any real self reflection whatever
happens it only proves what they already
thought so that's the fascinating thing
for Calvin here is that after all of
this it only proved what he already knew
to be the case fascinating how that
works all right before we move on I want
to tell you about Veritas press and as
you know someone with four kids myself
this this is very important for me if
you have kids I want you to pay
attention Veritas press is the leader in
providing a classical Christian
curriculum in online courses every child
whether homeschooled or in a traditional
school setting should know the
significance and application of history
in their own lives and Veritas makes
that happen it's not just about
remembering names and dates and places
and being able to regurgitate that
information when I went to public school
that's what history was all about it was
just about regurgitating information
memorizing the dates and then putting it
down on a piece of paper but this is so
much more than that this you know this
breathes life into the history makes it
comes come a lot alive so that children
can sort of experience it for themselves
in a way and learn these courses are the
most exciting way to learn your child
will experience history as never before
and they're gonna want to continue
learning that's the other thing about
education it should it should be
self-perpetuating it should you learn
and you should want to learn more that's
a really important aspect of Education
that's often lost but with Veritas press
it's definitely not every feature of
every course is designed to engage your
child and what they're learning with
games videos interactions to win your
child's attention and foster a love of
learning it's all about that the love of
learning your child will be able to
learn his or her own her own pace and
you'll have one less subject to teach
saving yourself valuable time when you
sort of delegate that to Veritas press
best of all your child will master the
material guarantee if you're not
satisfied that
you get your money back and as listeners
to this show you can save $100 on every
self-paced course you purchase go to
Veritas press comm slash Walsh choose
your subjects like your course use the
code Walsh at checkout that's Veritas
press.com slash Walsh okay here's a
picture I think first posted by Abby
Johnson prominent pro-life activist and
and then it was and live action also
took it posted it so take a look here at
this picture
they say this is abortionist / serial
killer LeRoy Carhart and if you're in
the pro-life movement at all or if
you're familiar with it then you're
familiar with that name LeRoy Carhart
he's a one of the you know he's one of
the most prominent abortionist he's also
done thousands of late term abortions
well here he is celebrating his birthday
ironically and remember of course he's
killed a lot of babies in his day that's
his specialty the kind of human he
specializes in killing especially are
the you know late term babies but you
see that sign on his desk
the sign says even on my worst day I'm
killing it now I just want to show you
that because do you think that's a
coincidence do you think that's there by
accident obviously not this is entirely
intentional and I'll tell you how I know
it's intentional one because
abortionists are sick and evil and
deranged people so you think about those
undercover tapes at Planned Parenthood
where Planned Parenthood officials were
joking about killing babies and joking
about hey if they sell enough dead
babies they can get a Lamborghini this
is very common among abortionist and in
that realm this kind of quote-unquote
humor these are really absurdly
cartoonishly evil people like if
abortion didn't exist and I wrote a
screenplay with characters like this
with guys like LeRoy Carhart you would
say that it just
it's it's way too outlandish to be
believable and here's the other thing
LeRoy Carhart as someone who performs
late term abortions absolutely knows and
acknowledges that he kills living babies
and I know that he acknowledges that
that he kills babies because he said so
himself I want to play this for you this
basically got no attention when it first
came out but I think it deserves a lot
more attention than that the BBC did a
report on the abortion war in America as
they as they called it and as part of
that report they interviewed this guy
LeRoy Carhart and I want to show you a
just a brief clip of that interview
listen to this what counts as a medical
need in your view I mean if the woman is
really stressed about her pregnancy has
to get more to the point of depression
not just stress and it it fit within my
confidence of what we could do safely I
would do that right up until when late
38 weeks 39 weeks so know that you're
not comfortable saying no to the fetus
it makes no difference whether it's born
or not one the baby has no input in this
as far as I'm concerned but it's
interesting that you use the word baby
because a lot of abortionists won't use
that they'll use the word fetus because
they don't want to acknowledge that it
is a baby and I use it with the patients
and you don't have a problem absolutely
killing a baby I have no problem if it's
in the mother's uterus there's just so
much in that one little clip and all of
it is utterly devastating to the
standard pro-abortion arguments first of
all he admits you caught that at the
very beginning there it's just really
important he admits that performing late
term abortions in cases where you know
he's supposedly doing it for the health
and life of the mother he admits that in
many of those cases it's the the medical
issue that the mother suffers from is
depression
so keep that in mind keep that in mind
whenever someone says and you hear this
all the time you hear people say that Oh
late term abortions that's not even a
problem this is just something that
pro-lifers make up or something that
anti-choice people make up as they would
phrase it because if you're if someone's
doing a late term abortion it's only
because the mother's health is seriously
in jeopardy and they got to do it to
save her life
not according to LeRoy Carhart who
actually performs the abortions he's
saying that if a mother comes to him and
says I'm depressed about being pregnant
that is a quote medical reason to get an
abortion which actually makes a lot of
sense because this idea that a person at
at a late statement stage of pregnancy
could have some sort of actual physical
medical complication that would
necessitate an abortion is is ridiculous
now it's very possible that a woman in
the later stages of pregnancy could have
a serious physical medical complication
that would mean that she can no longer
carry the baby but in those cases if
you're interested in preserving
preserving the baby's life you would
just deliver the baby alive
doctors do this all the time in
hospitals all across America they have
emergency c-sections and so on it's a
very common thing but with late term
abortions now if it's a late term
abortion there is going to be a delivery
either way
the baby's coming out it's going to be
delivered the only question is are you
going to kill the baby before you
deliver him or not so with the late term
abortion all you're doing is adding an
extra step and that extra step happens
to involve killing a human being there
is no way that that extra step of
killing the baby first could somehow be
necessary in order to save the mother's
life no that's not what it's about it's
just about killing the baby for the sake
of killing a baby and the medical
complication is often something like
she's just emotionally traumatized by
the fact that she's pregnant
but it doesn't end there he also then
justifies abortion by saying that it
makes no difference to the baby if the
baby is born or not born the baby has no
input he says now this is of course
callous and cruel in the extreme but
this is the kind of rationale that that
abortionists use I think sometimes it
surprises people to learn that
abortionists especially when they're
talking amongst themselves now in this
case he's talking to a reporter so he
was being a little bit more honest than
than usually they're willing to be but
abortionists don't they don't bother
with all the euphemisms and everything
often times that that people in the
pro-abortion movement do they know what
they're doing
and their reason for doing it is just
hey you know the baby just doesn't mean
anything to me I don't care but of
course with that attitude to say it
makes no difference to the baby if it's
born or not born which I suppose is
another way of saying that the baby
isn't really you know isn't fully
conscious of what's going on and and is
doesn't have quite this the
self-awareness you know that a that a
human does later in development which is
which is true but of course if that
justifies abortion then it would justify
killing an infant six months after birth
or a year after birth and I suspect that
a guy luckily we're a Carhartt would
have no problem with that if it was
legal he would do that too and then
finally he says that he calls them
babies he says the other babies I'm
killing babies sure he's got no problem
saying that he even calls the baby a
baby to the to the mother he even calls
the mother a mother which just shows you
that all the talking points all the
obfuscation all the ways that pro aborts
tried to sanity
is this well for the guy who's actually
doing the deed
that's all useless and it's useless
because he knows what he's doing he
knows what he sees it for himself he
knows what this he knows that course is
a baby I'm dealing with here what else
would it be
it's just that he's got himself to a
point he's gotten his soul to a point or
he has sufficiently removed his soul
forfeited his soul to a point where
where it doesn't bother him all right um
let's see here we have this I mentioned
this interesting article in The
Federalist that I think we'll save for
tomorrow but I do want to talk about
this because Chad Felix green who's a
great writer over at the Federalist he
wrote a report analyzing this claim that
there's a an epidemic of anti-trans hate
crimes I'm sure you've heard this claim
many times in fact we heard it at the
that Democrat town hall a couple months
ago where a someone got up and was
screaming about how there's a people are
I'm pretty sure the phrase was a claim
that people are out hunting trans people
well Chad Felix green took a look at
that at this claim and he took a look at
the actual supposed instances of
anti-trans hate crimes and found
unsurprisingly
that this is an epidemic that doesn't
exist and we'll talk more about that
tomorrow
because although it's been a pretty dark
show in some ways I feel like I
unfortunately have to continue that
trend and show you another disturbing
clip this one from a Pete Budaj rally
these are footage supporters and look at
what they're caught on tape doing
the way that the dance goes is very very
simple you kind of like a push down to
the right and then down to the left and
then up to the right and up to the left
super simple down and then you do the
same thing but you do a roll all the
right roles are the less you can roll up
sit right and wrong to the left and then
you do two cuts and then they drop in I
can for now just up in the air right so
it looks like this to the music and I
encourage you all to do it along with me
so they don't feel silly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know what I changed my mind
white people are actually bad I you know
it abolished white people that's my
feeling the alt-right accuses me of
being anti white which which I've always
found to be an idiotic and incoherent
accusation but maybe they're right maybe
I am anti white I think because all I'm
saying is if if you if you can't dance
which it's a stereotype but it's true
that most white people can many
stereotypes are based in truth this one
definitely is my feeling is if you can't
dance then it is unethical and
irresponsible for you to attempt it when
other people are present you are
subjecting them to that no I can't dance
I can't sing so you know what I don't
dancer sing because I'm not gonna
subject others to the horrific spectacle
of me attempting to do that I don't
think it's socially responsible and so
this is this is socially irresponsible
what you're seeing there
which brings us inevitably to this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
come
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes Sean Spicer is still on Dancing with
the Stars and his dancing is getting
worse each time his outfits are getting
worse each time it's almost like he's
doing it on purpose
and Buddy got voted through again I
think last night didn't it now look I'm
gonna say this I don't say it lightly I
mean every word of it
the people responsible for this
continued spectacle of Sean Spicer
dancing those people are domestic
terrorists this is an act of domestic
terrorism by voting Sean Spicer through
you are tearing at the very fabric of
our society think of the children who
are being exposed to this I my son saw
this and he came up to me and he said
daddy what is that man doing I'm scared
and I said me too son me too and these
are conversations that that if you're
voting Sean spies the Spicer through
you're forcing all of us to have this I
don't want to have to explain this to my
kids that what what's what's happening
on that screen what that man is doing I
don't know that's not a conversation I
want to have and now I have to explain
to my kid I mean cuz in MI and then my
son said to me well you know I'm white
does that mean that what I dance I'm
gonna look like that and I said to him
I'm yes
I'm sorry probably and he broke down in
tears
it's outrageous all right let's uh get
to a couple emails Matt well show at
gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
this is from Brian says Matt as to your
dilemma on the plane I respect you
saying no I probably would have relented
but only out of sheer awkwardness your
conscience should be clear go in peace
yes Brian is referring to an interesting
dilemma that I was talking about of
social media last night let me see what
you guys think of this I am interested
in your in your input so here's the
situation I was boarding a flight in
Baltimore for Los Angeles yesterday
Southwest flight I had I was in boarding
position a4 so anyone who flies
Southwest you know that of course did
get Southwest you pick your own seats so
ever gets on the plane first you get
your pick of the litter and I was one of
the first people to get on the plane
with my position
a4 I was and I can't play how excited I
was when I saw my that a4 position on my
on my on my boarding pass and I was so
high I was so excited I skipped onto the
plane whistling that's how happy I was
if you can believe it and I looked and I
I you know I'm very I'm very scientific
about choosing what seat it's because of
course I'm gonna take an aisle seat but
I also am trying to figure out where on
the plane I want to be I don't wanna be
too far in the back but also want to be
too far too close to the front in case
the plane crashes because then you know
the further back you are the better also
if you're more towards the middle
there's you feel the turbulence a little
bit less then I'm also thinking about
you know did I want to be I don't want
to be too close to the front because
then probably I'm gonna end up with
someone sitting in the middle next to me
maybe if I'm a little bit maybe I can
sort of lose myself towards the back
anyway so I had this whole process I
picked my seat well about nine hours
later when Group C was boarding a guy
comes on with his wife only middle seats
are left you know if you're like c30 and
later then you're screwed it's just you
you you're gonna be in a middle seat
that's all there is to it or you look
your order you'd have to sit in the
overhead bin even perhaps maybe they'll
put you down below tie you to a wing or
something like that so this guy comes on
with his wife he's only got middle seats
they're got to sit in different rows and
middle seats this guy decides to sit in
my row
in the middle seat but then he asks me
if I wouldn't mind moving to a different
seat moving from my aisle seat to a
middle seat in a different row so that
his wife consider excellent that's what
he asked me if I would again move from
my aisle seat to a middle seat here's
the question that I posed and I've
gotten thousands of answers to it which
I wasn't quite expected who is the jerk
here me for saying no which I did say no
I said that's a that's a I did I did
refused I declined that invitation I
said I'm gonna stick with with my seat
thank you very much
so who's the jerk me for saying no and
refusing to let the guys in next to his
wife or him for asking in the first
place
or are we both innocent doves
I guess that's also an option obviously
I'm biased here I'd like to hear your
thoughts don't let my analysis influence
you at all but it seems to me that
asking someone to switch from an aisle
seat to a middle seat
you just don't do that I fly all the
time I've never been asked that I've
never heard anyone asked that before you
know the middle seat for a six-hour
flight there's a reason why his wife
then want to sit in it right so um to
ask a stranger to take on that
discomfort seems I don't know it seems
tacky to me to put it mildly now if his
traveling companion was a young child
and he wanted us next to his kid then
yeah I would do it or if there was some
other extenuating circumstances his wife
was sick or something then you know that
that would be different but he didn't
express any extenuating circumstance it
sounded like he just wanted to sit next
to his wife and that just is not good
enough it's a pretty significant
sacrifice he's asking me to make without
giving me any real reason why I should
and so I had to say no it's kind of like
imagine if you went to the movies and
you got to the movies early because you
wanted to pick your seat you picked a
seat you know you picked seats like in
the middle row also in the in the middle
of the middle row so you've got your
perfect
lined up with the screen not too far
back not too close and then imagine that
some other people come thirty seconds
before the movie starts and they come up
to you and they say would you mind
getting up and moving to a worse seat so
we can sit there would you ever do that
would you actually say well if you of
course yes sit down because here's my
thing if in that situation you did get
up and give the person your seat it's
not because you're being nice it's just
because you're a punk who got who got
bullied out of your seat just because
you felt too awkward saying no and so
you wimped out and gave him what he
wanted it's not because you're being
generous anyway that's my that's my case
for myself but I will surprise anumber
of people said that I was the jerk in
the situation which I don't know if that
if they really feel that way or if
they're just if their view is clouded by
the fact that I'm a jerk in general and
so they just assumed that I was a jerk
here which I don't look I don't deny
that I'm a jerk I'm just saying that
doesn't make me a jerk in this
particular situation you have to
separate the two this is from Yehuda
says good afternoon mat about a month
ago I started listening to your show in
my drive home and I've thoroughly
enjoyed I appreciate your views on
relationships in marriage one thing you
mentioned yesterday was the benefit of
getting married a young age my wife and
I married seven months ago I was 20 she
was 19 we are expecting a child in three
months I know I'm newlywed but I can I
can support your point that I know my
wife is a totally different person than
when she went then then she was when I
proposed that being said so am i I love
her more and more every day I have never
been with another woman nor do I have
any regret on not playing the field I
guess I don't have a question just want
to express my appreciation for your
outlook on marriage which I find myself
consistently agreeing with even though
I'm an Orthodox Jew and you're a
Christian now I'm wondering was this the
guy who wanted to sit next to his wife
on the plane cuz now I'm starting to
feel guilty that is one thing that
occurred to me it's like you really
don't want to be apart from your wife
for six hours
I mean I'm just I'm just saying like you
can't I think there are a lot of married
couples who would say hey it's that's
fine I'll sit by myself in silence for
six hours that's cool so the very fact
that you would be so desperate to sit
next to your wife for six hours when
you're when you're
there all the time anyway maybe they
were newlyweds maybe they were going on
their honeymoon and they were just so in
love with each other they couldn't
darling I can't be apart from you
they were City Leah sitting there
texting and I don't know if they were
actually texting each other but you know
anyway I don't know if that would that
make me a jerk then in that case if they
were newlyweds and I forced them to be a
partner in that way no but thanks thanks
for the email and congratulations on on
the marriage by the way I think you guys
made a great decision as I said
yesterday I'm a big proponent of
marrying young it's not for everybody of
course we all have to make decisions
that are right for us in our particular
situations but I certainly think that
it's something that once you know once
you're an adult and you leave the house
it's something to at least consider and
starting that journey together and I
think you guys will be be happy that you
did so congratulations again finally
this is from Michael says I'm a
libertarian conservative and agree with
much of what you say I agree on
conservative values but do not believe
the government should be used to push
said values on the topic of allowing
people to kill themselves I disagree
with you I do not want anyone to kill
themselves and what this is a
assisted-suicide we're talking about as
we've been discussing in the email
portion for last few days I do not want
anyone to kill themselves and would do
all I could to convince that person
otherwise but as bad as an action as it
might be for the person as you said I
don't see why it it's the state's job to
prohibit that take legalization of drugs
a person should be allowed to do all the
drugs they want as long as no one else
is harmed and this might not be in their
best interest but they're still a free
individual just as I would try to stop a
person from committing suicide I'd try
the same for drug addict at the end of
the day it is still their choice and
they are not physically harming anyone
else in the process so it's okay how do
you disagree and can you change my mind
well I can only say I've got so many
emails on this and people making the
same point Michael I can only repeat
what I've been saying that first of all
we're talking about assisted suicide so
we're not talking really about whether
or not a person in an individual has the
right to kill themselves we're saying
does a third party have the right to
come in and get involved and especially
when the third part
is someone a representative of the
medical industry which is supposed to be
focused on healing and treating disease
not killing people and what I would say
is that no so this is really focused on
that third party I think that so even if
I agreed that you have a right to kill
yourself whatever that could possibly
mean I don't think that anyone else has
a right to help you
and if you are saying that someone has a
right to help another person kill
themselves you can't do it on a
self-determination basis because it's
not self-determination you're helping to
determine someone else's self or rather
to obliterate someone else's self so
there's that also I would just say on
the libertarian thing I sympathize with
libertarian views in many respects
especially when it comes to taxes and
economics but I do think that the reason
why I don't myself identify as a
libertarian is because you you go it's
it can be a bit too simplistic at times
where you completely disregard the
concept of the public good and any
notion that the state should be at all
involved in fortifying protecting
facilitating promoting the public good
to you is anathema as a libertarian I
just disagree with that now I agree that
many times the state can do things that
it says are for the public good but
actually are not so I I don't so that's
bad I agree that that is bad and there
are other things that could be for the
public good but maybe the state should
not still shouldn't get involved in
because it's not their place but to just
sweep that consideration off the table
completely and say that the state has no
role here at all
I disagree it in fact I think that that
is one of the roles of the state it's
just they have to do it right and we as
free people and in a democratic society
you know we have the power to or we
should have the power anyway to see that
it is done right so for example
something like legalizing drugs
I'm legalizing marijuana fine I just I
don't the the the the cost in terms of
money and manpower and and and
everything pain and suffering involved
in in enforcing laws against it just is
not worth it when you consider what
marijuana is which is a you know
relatively benign in comparison with
other substances that are that are
actually legal such as alcohol and a lot
of prescription drugs and so on so I'm
so that's why I'm okay with legalizing
marijuana but the idea of legalizing all
drugs for example heroin intravenous
heroin the idea of having a situation
where you could just go to the drugstore
and pick up intravenous heroin I know I
can't get on board with that I respect
that you're taking your view to its
logical conclusion as a libertarian and
saying that well you know it may not be
great for society to have heroin legal
for everyone and you could go buy it at
the store but the state has no role
there I just disagree I think that the
state does have a role there largely for
the sake of the public good in that case
ok we'll leave it there thanks everybody
for watching thanks for listening
thank you for your emails as well
Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer his Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena Matt
Walsh show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2019 if you want to
delve the depths of leftist madness head
on over to the Michael Noel's show where
we examine what's really going on
beneath the surface of our politics and
bask in the simple joys of being right
[Music]
you